it is July 17 2023 and you're watching
the code report the internet has a big
problem when you look at an image how do
you know if it's real this image of the
Pope tricked millions of grandmas
worldwide when you hear someone's voice
how do you know it's real this is not my
real voice it's a professional clone
from 11 Labs my biggest fear as a
digital Creator is that tools like this
will be used to fully replicate my
online Swagger and make me irrelevant
it's already happening to people like I
legit thought that Greta launched her
own Oil Company recently hello my name
is Greta and welcome to my oil company I
love how it is pumped out of the ground
I'm a huge fan of oil and use it all the
time as you can see here in this
documentary from Honeypot that borrowed
my deepake animatron to make it look
like I'm not AI generated luckily though
there's a new Coalition in town that
includes friendly Mega corporations like
Adobe and Microsoft who have stepped up
to rescue us from these generative AI
problems that they created it's called
the Coalition for Content Providence and
authenticity or c2pa not many people
know about it yet but it should be on
every developer's radar because it could
change the internet as we know it
basically it's a spec or set of
guidelines for both hardware and
software providers that would attach
metadata to every media file like images
videos audio and so on then use
cryptography to digitally sign it making
every file tamper aware the idea is to
make it impossible to change a pixel
without the provenance of those changes
being recorded on the file itself or to
a manifest that is permanently attached
to that file the first record will
happen on the camera where the photo is
taken then when you go to edit in
Photoshop another record will be logged
and signed there it's almost like every
image will become an nft minus the
blockchain you'll be able to click on
this icon to inspect the provenance
information to determine if that image
was generated by AI or determine if it
comes from a trusted news source like
BuzzFeed or Infowars this technology is
already here and just last week the
Coalition was urging the U.S Senate to
put laws on the books that would make
this technology essential we propose
Congress established a new federal
anti-impersonation right that would give
artists a right to enforce against
someone intentionally attempting to
impersonate their style or likeness that
actually sounds great as a Creator I
don't want to be impersonated and as an
end user I want to make sure that I'm
consuming authentic content and it would
be very useful to companies like valve
who have recently started Banning games
on Steam that are suspected of using AI
generated content that could potentially
violate someone's copyright and other
top companies like stability AI are
fully on board and it just generated
throughout platform can be digitally
stacked with metadata and watermarks to
welcome adobe's leadership in driving
the development of some of these Open
Standards and not surprisingly the US
Department of Defense is on board
because they believe this technology can
help surface Bad actors like Steven
Seagal or anyone else creating horrible
synthetic content sounds pretty awesome
and I love when big corporations team up
with the government to keep me safe but
when looked at from another angle this
can be viewed as a mass surveillance
apparatus in the future it may be
impossible to change a pixel on the
internet without leaving a digital
footprint currently the spec allows for
anonymity but it talks about how this
technology can be used with digital IDs
issued by the government that would make
it far easier to figure out who's
creating all these memes that are
offensive to our dear leaders when this
technology is combined with a digital
currency and social credit system we
could easily shut down the meme Warriors
internet access and reduce their
allowance of lab grown meat to just 12
ounces per week in addition it would
give the establishment a monopoly on
disinformation hypothetically they could
create all the AI generated content they
want while making it look trustworthy
and the vast majority of people out
there will believe whatever authorities
tell them like if this image had a NASA
prominent signature on it almost
everybody would believe that we went to
Mars even though it's not a real place
you can go to in 1981 the CIA director
said we'll know our disinformation
program is complete when everything in
the American public believes is false
this has been the code report thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one